moi je considère que la france n'a pas
de politique proactive pour faire
revenir ces personnes mais que quand
elles reviennent quand elles reviennent
elles sont dès leur arrivée sur le sol
français
elles sont immédiatement judiciariser
présenté à un juge
les sommes placées en garde à vue les
femmes également son judiciariser et les
enfants aussi
tous sont judiciariser et une décision
adaptée est prise au cas par cas c'est
pour ça que contrairement à ce que dit
madame la sénatrice benbassa j'ai pas de
solution généralisée a proposé j'ai une
solution au cas par cas mais c'est au
cas par cas
nous avons actuellement dans nos
statistiques 244 personnes majeures qui
sont revenus 68 femmes je crois où j'ai
à peu près je n'ai plus en tête même
douce et 56 mineurs en plus tous sont
judiciariser tous pains n'échappe à
notre à notre suivi qui évidemment comme
à des radars a pas du tout aimé vous
entendent également ce que nous
entendons également c'est à dire une
justice spéciale est-ce qu'il faut
établir cette justice spéciale pour les
retours du terrorisme mais il y a que
séchage nam il y à déjà ils sont tous
présentés au parquet antiterroriste qui
vous le savez se situe à paris c'est un
parquet spécial avarie donc il ya des
jeux c'est pas une justice spéciale
justice qui est organisée de manière
singulière c'est pas une justice
spéciale au sens de justice d'exception
mais c'est une justice qui est
d'organiser de manière singulière centré
justice d'exception ça pourrait être
envisageable au parc non pardon je
répète en tant que garde des sceaux
je n'aime pas ce terme là une justice
organisé et adapté de manière spéciale
oui justice d'exception alors